newsom cuomo
whitmer now they're all once touted as
heroes by the liberal media
but they're all now on the ropes
politically and for good reason
months of draconian coveted lockdowns
residents fleeing their states
mismanaged vaccine rollouts
has these blue state bozos sucking wind
big time but it's california governor
gavin newsom who faces the most severe
and serious challenge
the effort to recall him now has more
than 1.1 million signatures
now that's up from 500 000 when this
show
first highlighted it just a couple of
months ago
now one of the lawmakers who has been
instrumental in leading that effort
california state senator
melissa melendez joins me now state
senator melendez
um now organizers need 1.5 million
by mid-march to place this recall on the
ballot
are you gonna get there will they get
there
well laura always good to see you and
yes absolutely we are going to get there
without a doubt you've seen
you know the increased numbers just in
the past couple of months
and i think gavin newsom knows it too
which is why he's been talking about the
recall now
and those who are opposed to him in his
press conferences you know you've gotten
under their skin when they start talking
about you
uh a lot of people in the tech world are
just deciding to move out of the city
in san francisco and at least move to
the countryside but in general
they have a problem with people fleeing
the beautiful state of california
because it's not livable or it's not
it's not affordable it's not livable
and it's locked down for most of the
time
yeah i mean i have to wonder what took
them so long to realize that it was just
unlivable and
unaffordable because it's like that all
over the state especially so in the bay
area of course
but the governor you know he rolls at
his new budget he's got a billion and a
half dollars in there
for hybrid vehicle infrastructure
you know you've got people out of work
he's got an unemployment department that
can't manage to get people's you know
benefits out to them
and he's spending a billion and a half
dollars on electric vehicles
i mean this guy he just he does not
understand how the average person
lives and what they need and what he
just doesn't get it
now you still have the welcome mat out
though for illegal immigrants because
that's not a drain on the state at all
now the mayor of long beach said this
about
that million plus joining this effort
watch
some of the same forces that we have
seen
that are anti-immigrant uh that have
pushed back against people of color in
our state
uh that have really demonized low-income
folks up and down our state
are also behind these same recall
efforts
now other democrat critics called this a
a coup
your reaction yeah
i would say nice try i mean even the
liberal
news media in california of all places
called bs on this one they said
like are you kidding me this is this is
something that is constitutionally
allowed
you cannot call it a coup simply because
you don't like that it's happening
i mean come on this is i i hope that
they decide to
try a different tack because that one
clearly doesn't work there is no coup
taking place what is taking place is
californians are saying look gavin
newsom
you're not fit to lead and we're going
to find somebody who can
now senator melendez i want you to hear
something from the fresno
city council manager about this whole
controversy of the recall
the same folks who participated in this
un-american assault on democracy
are the same folks behind the effort to
recall governor newsom this is where
these detractors choose to spend their
energy
republicans are busy uh pushing their
political agendas that kind of
treasonous behavior won't be tolerated
here in california
what what do you say to that i would say
what treason what are you talking about
what treason
we're unhappy with his leadership we're
unhappy with how he's governing this
state into the ground
that it's not treason that's patriotism
if you ask me i mean
i'm sorry they can talk all day long
about how they think this is some sort
of
coup and hostile takeover it's just not
no matter how many times they say it
they know it they're just trying to get
people whipped up into a frenzy
and act like victims the only victims
are the california business owners
who've been shut down for months and
months and months and the people who
can't work
and the people who can't pay their bills
those are the victims not gavin newsom
but at least you'll have all those
hybrid vehicles and
and health care for illegal immigrants
that joe biden talked about this week
everybody everybody's getting health
care for free everything's free
no one has to pay apparently it's just
this is just la la land senator
melandez great to see you tonight thanks
so much thanks laura appreciate it